hello I'm Sam this is my channel this is
that Wikipedia list and this is that
Wikipedia list September 3rd 1967 Sweden
decides to switch from left to right
Swedish motorists accustomed to left
side of the road driving join the
growing trend throughout Europe the
crossover to right side traffic flow
that was a crazy day for Sweden prior to
1967 Sweden much like many other
European countries drove on the left
most countries in the world in fact
began driving on the left because that's
how carriages did it and carriages did
it that way because that's how horses
did it the rules start in the first
place because back in the old days most
would brandish their sword on their
right side so in writing they wanted to
be able to respond to an oncoming
attacker on the right side
archaeological evidence proves that left
side riding was the norm throughout much
of the ancient world the shifter right
side riding came when freight wagons got
larger as trade became more common
demand grew so Teamsters the old term
for wagon drivers started adding more
and more horses to pull heavier and
heavier loads
there weren't seats on these wagons so
Teamsters just sat on a horse
most chose to sit on the back left horse
so they could whip with their right hand
since the vast majority of people
especially at the time were right hand
dominant therefore the Teamsters chose
to ride on the right side of the road so
that oncoming wagons could pass on their
left and they could clearly see that
their wheels were clear fast forward two
hundred years and sixty-five percent of
the world's population drives on the
right side of the road which as it turns
out is the worst side to drive on you
see humans are naturally right-side
dominant as we know the vast majority of
the world's population is right-handed
about 90% but the vast majority of the
world is also right eye dominant humans
actually do have an eye that works
better than the other for about 70
percent of the world's population that's
the right eye while driving on the left
the right eye will focus on oncoming
traffic while the left will see what's
passing by this may contribute to the
slightly lower accident rate in
left-side driving countries anyways
let's get back to Dagon H the name for
the day Sweden switched in 1955 Sweden
held a referendum on the issue of
driving directionality and a staggering
83% voted
against changing the direction the
national legislature known as the
Riksdag promptly responded by deciding
to make the change the rationale was
that every single one of Sweden's
neighbors drove on the right and most
importat cars which were the cheapest
cars were designed to be driven on the
right in the months leading up to Dagon
H every intersection was outfitted with
an extra set of signals and signs
wrapped in black plastic eight thousand
buses were retrofitted with new doors on
the right side and the rest were sold to
Pakistan and Kenya new lines were
painted on the roads then covered in
black tape milk cartons and underwear
with the day's logo were sold in stores
around the country contests were held
for songs about the change then finally
on September 3rd 1967 at 3:00 p.m. the
law switch and the entire country had
one enormous traffic jam as drivers
slowly inch across the white line to get
to the new normal
no one died that day on Swedish roads in
fact nobody died the day after as well
there were only 125 collisions compared
to the average of 164 it seemed that the
switch worked
however by 1969 collision rates were
back to normal it turned out that the
roads were only safer because drivers
were more cautious as they learn the new
traffic patterns I'll end with an only
somewhat related but interesting tidbit
the Geneva Conventions have a treaty
that outlines international rules of the
road including the rule that traffic
directionality must be uniform
throughout the same country the vast
majority of countries follow this rule
with no problem however the good old US
of A holds the territory of the US
Virgin Islands where all drivers drive
on the left and therefore the u.s. is
technically in violation of the Geneva
Conventions which as the no longer
existent country of Yugoslavia knows is
kind of a big deal
anyways I hope you enjoyed this video
make sure to click subscribe to catch
more episodes of that Wikipedia list and
other videos I make you can also follow
me on twitter at Wendover pro
additionally you can check out my last
video on the secret symbol that stops
you from copying money hear or watch an
old video of mine on space law here
lastly I think it's worth mentioning
that I've been putting out videos far
less frequently recently I work
seasonally in outdoor recreation and
summer is a really big time for that so
I just don't have as much video making
time when Smid August rolls
I'll be back to releasing videos almost
every week